are there videos
pictures that you've seen that are not
so grainy not so far away but instead up
close
exact let's say such that someone who is
on the fence about this issue would no
longer be on the fence yeah and i think
you're seeing that with congress i mean
there's
there's videos and photographs and
reporting that i've been privy to
that are extremely compelling i've said
for the record that the three videos
that have come out as
interesting as they are they're probably
the least compelling of the ones that
that
you know we had and and this is why i'm
so concerned about now the recent
revelations that
the pentagon has deleted or destroyed my
emails and my
my my files because there were documents
on in a very comprehensive shared folder
that we had
that was was that was you know pretty
incredible
i mean there was some some very high
definition high fidelity videos in there
that when you looked at it you realize
hey
you know that's that's not one of our
aircraft